Lari is with us in Niagara Falls hi Lori
how are you thank you mr. Ramsey for
taking my call sure what's up my husband
and I are reconciling a 25 year old
marriage and our financial situation is
a disaster we run a family farm and I'm
coming up to nearly complete reluctance
to do anything different
the insanity thing I need something to
take away to start to get together with
him and make process to progress to
reduce our debt okay um I didn't
understand what you meant when you said
you're reconciling a 25-year marriage
what does that mean we've we've been
married 25 years and we've been
separated for two and we're coming back
together and proceeding with our
marriage and our family okay
and why were you separated um we had a
lot of arguing and differences and how
to actually do different things to get
out of that and it was just a very
difficult complex situation yeah yeah
and did you have someone coach you as
you work through this reconcile
reconciliation process you did for short
we did for a short time together but
that didn't go much more than a few
months and I've been in counseling
myself privately uh-huh okay and your
current counselor is telling you that
this process you're using is going to
work
it doesn't sound very healthy to me it
is not the best but it could be worse
I'm hopeful well a lot of things to be
worth somebody shooting you would be
worse but there's a lot of things that
are worse but that doesn't mean that I
mean it sounds to me like you're the
only one that's working on this pretty
much
okay I think you need to go talk to your
counselor again and I think your
counselor needs to tell you the truth
that if you go back into a situation
when you're the only one that has
changed nothing's going to change
because the point is you're coming up
against an immovable object him and if
he is not going to change that is not
reconciliation that is that is you
acquiescing there's a difference
that's no you don't call that
reconciliation reconciliation is when
both parties say we both have to move to
a common ground from where we are in
order to go forward and I sure hope
we're I sure hope that can happen but
you know so far everything in this
conversation and it's a very short
conversation on the radio I understand
and I'm not your counselor but but but
you guys I mean there has to be some
movement on his side of this equation
progress has been made on a personal
level you know interpersonal or when it
when it comes and overflows into the
business aspect of it this is where
stalling out I mean being being together
and working together all day every day
and then having a relationship too it's
very difficult at times to differentiate
where the boundaries are between work
and personal yes sir so we have we have
made progress in the personal area but
when it comes to the finances and the
hard numbers there's a lot of reluctance
to explore new avenues of them it's a
new day and age in a world with
marketing and and pushing so you work in
the business still even though you're
separated I'm on the I help I'm on the
fringes I'm trying to mesh back in and
pick up you know where I was are you did
you used to work in the business yes yes
okay completely totally okay so here's
the thing the boundaries part that you
talked about here's a couple things you
can work on there you guys need to talk
about the hats I've got family in my
business here
I'm not kids work here they're grown
humans but I mean they're my children is
the same
and we wear hats and the hats are when
we're at home on Papa Dave to the
grandbabies
when I'm at the office I'm your freaking
CEO and you're my employee and you can't
be wifey at the office that doesn't work
and he can't be husband at the office
because you're disrespecting the CEO of
the organization and he can't lead and
he can't make decisions if you're
playing wifey at the office but can a
wife work in the office absolutely but
if you're the marketing director you
report to your CEO and if you're the CEO
and he's the marketing director he
reports to you I don't care which way it
is but you put those hats on at the
office because if the other team members
and the customers see you all having
marital disputes at the office / office
stuff that says you don't know what your
role is and family business
disintegrates into a toxic cesspool does
that sound familiar at all yes okay it's
a pain in the butt in it but I mean
we've had stuff like Rachel my daughter
is one of our MC personalities you may
know that right and and rachel is very
opinionated which makes her a great
speaker and writer and so forth you need
to have an opinion and and yet she works
at Christy writes her MC personality
when we're in a meeting with ten of us
working on the launch of Christy
Wright's book and I say something
Christy Wright does not roll her eyes
she's a she's an employee of mine I'm
the CEO right mm-hmm but Rachel Cruise
might have been known to do that once
can you imagine now if she rolled her
eyes what was she doing she had the
wrong head on she had the daughter had
on his daughters rolled their eyes at
their dads not employees you know I'm
saying correct and so guess what Rachel
got thumped by one of our other
executives here as soon as she did that
and she tells that story so I'm not
telling scout school on her but that was
an example of one time where we forgot
one of us forgot the
hat we were supposed to be wearing was
not father/daughter and I can't use my
dad voice on my son in a meeting he's
one of our senior directors and when I
treat him I got suing any other senior
director the same respect and I thumped
him just as hard as I would one of our
other senior directors if they were
doing something stupid in their business
unit you know treat them exactly the
same but I don't use my dad voice on my
son because it brings up all this other
toxic stuff so you really got to work on
that stuff in order to be able to have
the influence for him to hear you about
business stuff now once you've got those
hats established here's another way to
approach it then you leave the physical
location of the business and you sit
down over a nice meal and you say
alright we're changing hats now you're
not the CEO now you're the husband and
I'm your wife and as your wife I'm going
to speak into the financial decisions at
the business because they affect me
as your wife my wife does that and she
doesn't work here at all and so if we're
doing something here that she gets
nervous about her she doesn't understand
she doesn't hesitate from a wife's
position to sit down with me in private
and say hey Dave I'm worried about that
that thing down there I'm seeing this
I'm wondering about that I know I'm on
the outside but as a wife wearing the
wife hat she has she speaks into the
business but she doesn't stroll into the
office around here and go well you need
to do this and you needed that start
barking at people and telling them what
to do she doesn't work here she doesn't
have the position to do that the only
influence she has is the absolute most
powerful influence there is which is
through her husband right and so we're
not wearing the wife hat so I think if
you can establish these differences of
how you act at work and how you act at
home wearing different hats okay I'm
taking my husband hat off I'm asking you
to take your CEO hat off and I want you
to put your husband hat on and I want
you to hear from your wife not one of
your part-time employees that used to
work here full-time before we split up
right because on that basis you've got
very little input
a part-time employee on the fringes you
said right working I'm working back in
yeah but I know but you're not you're
not enough from a corporate standpoint
from a business standpoint any other
employee that was looking at that it was
in that kind of a role does not have
influence on the CEO because part-timers
don't have influence on the CEOs and so
you don't try to get at it from that
angle it's not going to work you got to
get away from the business and say part
of our marital package is that we have
this business and as a wife I want to
speak into that business not as a
part-time fringe employee and we're
going to separate the two of those hats
maybe that will help you guys but I
think both of you need to be in coaching
counseling on a reconciliation as long
as you've been married trying to put
this back together fact that he's not
attending that bothers me a lot this is
the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]